to the
second part of the morning
and we are having uh jana shafonova from
john hopkins university
are you okay
and she will be talking about profiling
of anti-water repertoires which is also
very interesting topic thank you
hello everyone uh thank you for the
introduction my name is jana and today
i'm going to
tell about computational analysis of
antibody reference to our and
immunoglobulin lasagna so this topic is
closely related to studying diseases
and past two years showed us that
there's still a lot of work because
we can see newly immersed viruses and
already immersed viruses accumulate new
mutations and of course we are
interested in
answering questions how our body can
respond to all these new threats
so when we talk about
fighting diseases we of course mean
studying immune systems and there are
two types of immune systems in our
bodies the first one is dna and the
second is adaptive so the innate immune
system is encoded in the germline
directly
and mechanism of it work in the same way
across all people so it's easy to
predict how it would behave
on the other side adaptive immunity is
not encoded in the genome directly and
it's highly unique to an individual so
there are two main components of
adaptive immunity b cells producing
antibodies and t cells producing t-cell
receptors today we will talk mostly
about antibodies antibiotics can be
viewed as a such a white shaped protein
and it has a special feature it can
recognize and neutralize pathogens or
pathogenic particles and we will use
immunological term antigen when we will
talk about this so usually one distant
antibody can neutralize and recognize
one distinct antigen of course that's
not always rule but
uh still in order to recognize a lot of
different antigens we need to develop a
lot of different antibodies and it's
very hard to encode all of them in the
genome directly so that's why
they present a result of special process
so first of all let's look at this
process and discuss what distant
antibodies mean
antibodies are developed by b cells that
have unique genomes in places called
immunoglobulin laci so in all other
genes this immunoglobulin lacy look like
this they present a family of
regions where v stands for variable
indigenes distance for diversity
and j genes where j stands for joining
in b cells this immunoglobulin loss i
look different and more specifically
they are affected by special process
called vdg recombination that randomly
selects one gene from each of those
families and concatenates them together
thus producing gene encoding one of
antibody chains it's called vdj sequence
so the diversity of antibodies is
primarily based on the diversity of
editorial combinations and this process
is not that simple it also includes a
lot of small events on the vd and tj
junctions so non-genomic nucleotides can
be inserted and also prefaces and
surfaces of these genes can be removed
so the diversity of edges sequences is
truly huge
but that's not the end
because
that's how we just generate the primary
diversity once antibody binds an antigen
immune system marks that's useful and
produce multiple copies of corresponding
b cell but it also introduces small
changes inside antibody genes in order
to improve binding properties of this
antibody and this process can be viewed
as an evolutionary process that happens
really fast just within several days we
can observe that a single antibody is
turned into a family of antibiotics some
of these mutations can be good some of
them can be bad uh there are additional
processes that controls uh
the antibodies and eliminate them from
the stream and promote good antibodies
so as a result antibody repertoirs
that's how we will call a collection of
antibodies in a single body are
extremely diverse and we are interested
in question how we can study them
so fortunately modern sequencing
technologies allow us to sequence
subsets of antibody repertoires using
aluminum asic or by ccs because the cdj
sequences are not that long they are
about 400 nucleotides so we can cover
them with a single read and if you
design specific primers to cover vdj
sequences then we can collect
bjj sequences from a
set of b cells
and uh analyze
this antibody repertoires as a set of
sequences
so what kind of questions we can answer
using this analysis
um of course we are interested in
translating antibody repertoires in
antibody responses and here is a picture
of
uh from
one early paper about
poverty responses when the amarone
vaccine was developed and it was tested
on people who were exposed to poets so
they have recovered patients and or
native donors who never see them coveted
so you see that
after the vaccination that's here
responses go up in those groups however
we still see that this distributions are
truly wide and some people respond much
worse compared to others and also the
medium value still goes up and that's
what we expect to see is how the vaccine
works they're still interested in
explaining these variants
and using
repertoire sequencing data can give us
some answers how to explain this
so
we still see antibody repertoires as a
collection of sequences so the simplest
way would be just to see overlap between
to the set and find charge sequences
but unfortunately it doesn't always work
and for many diseases we don't see such
public repertoire antibodies at all and
even if we see them they might represent
just frequently the general combination
and
not necessarily
be
functional and important antibiotics
however surprisingly it's exactly what
we see for quality and i will come back
to this
um but for most cases it doesn't work so
we need to
understand some other representative
features and one of this feature could
be variation in original germline bd and
j genes
so currently we see a lot of such
associations detected by multiple groups
for example
uh
for influenza virus we see that most
responsive antibiotics are derived from
the same gene
ighv169
and this gene is highly polymorphic and
when we see variations in these genes we
sometimes see that people carrying
homozygous variation
of one type actually lose the ability to
develop this
antibodies so variations in these genes
can be truly important
but there are a lot of these genes this
you have 55 regions 27 digits and 7 j
genes so
it means that drug would be other
antibodies that can compensate for some
disadvantages alleles so how we can
study this that's a
complex problem and it's still a work in
progress and i will just to give you
just some example how it works for covet
for example when the pandemic just
started
a lot of antibody repertoires were
sequenced
and this repertoires whereas response
responders to the original virus it was
surprising to see that a lot of donors
developed the same antibodies so that's
actually contradictors what i said but
it was a truly big surprise for me so
they currently referred to as
stereotypic and they have
very conserved signature so they derived
from uh one of these two videos
353 or 366 and they also have a
recombination of dng genes that looks
like this so if we resemble this motif
and have one of these two genes then
surprisingly this antibodies can
recognize the original version of
coronavirus very well
and the target are the rpg part of the
spike protein but unfortunately they
glue to the top part that accumulates
most mutation so when viruses
when the virus mutated this antibodies
actually became useless and that's a
very sad story because they represent
the immunodominant part of the response
so they develop in most people and we
see that they actually
are the most popular antibodies
but we still need to live with this
somehow and uh
in addition to this antibodies we still
developed a lot of others so our goal is
to
see non-dominant responses and analyze
how they can be useful in new versions
of the virus so recently we published a
paper where we analyzed a subset of
neutralizing antibodies and we actually
derived one common feature in them so we
uh called it five id xsg and this is a
motif that actually allows antibodies to
bind a more conservative part of rbd and
they can uh recognize and neutralize not
only the original verses of the virus
but also some amicron subvariants other
existing variants such as delta
beta and gamma and also sars1 and north
so you see that there is a different
class of antibodies they still bind rbd
but they are much more versatile
so well then we decided to see
what is a fraction of this antibodies in
the population
and it was very pleasant to see that in
unexposed people the fraction of this
antibodies is four percent which is
extremely high so it means that it's
very easy to develop such antibodies and
that's a hope for future vaccine design
so even if this antibiotics are dominant
and practically useless although it's a
bit of
of an overreaction this antibodies still
can be boosted and maybe with a slight
change of
vaccine where this part can be more
exposed you can actually
change the production of good antibodies
so you see that uh
this
two different types and they are derived
from different v and regions this
antibodies are basically derived from
djinn 322 and we are interested in
studying this picture
in my general picture how all genes
can develop immune responses how they
communicate with each other so we
started with gene v366
and we analyzed a cohort of healthy
people
and for these people we sequenced the
immunoglobulin lasagna before pgj
recombination so germline
composition of this laci and also
antibody repertoires so for all these
people we listed a list of single
nuclear polymorphisms and performed utl
analysis with expression of each of
these genes for gene 366 you can see
that there is a
spot where a lot of smps are associated
with the usage of this gym and it's
actually a pretty wide spot but there is
a smaller spot that uh flanked
specifically this gym and has all top
associations approximately five
kilobases and we also saw that there are
a lot of regulatory elements that
modulates the three-dimensional
architecture of the locus and it
actually creates an additional level of
complexity so we not only need to know
how specific genes can respond to
specific pathogens but we also need to
know how it all
uh
orchestrated together
and when we extended this analysis to
other genes we saw that the same
region controls the production of many
other genes for example i mentioned v169
that is associated with flu it's also
controlled by this region so it actually
gives us hope that we can unravel all
this uh
production and understand what kind of
antibiotics can be developed in the
context of different antigens
but unfortunately that's still not it uh
oh maybe fortunately so we still see
that antibodies are product of edgy
recombinations so variations are not
only a factor that influences the
production of antibiotics and if we for
example move to hiv a very tricky
pathogen that accumulates a lot of
mutation during the course of disease
then we'll see that many
neutralizing antibiotics present a
result not a vdg recombination but vddj
recombination and that's an abnormal
event it was observed
on the very small fractions and for a
long time it wasn't known if it's just
some sort of a bleach or if it's
systematic feature
so we decided to analyze it and we
collected such d diffusions across
different individuals the fraction is
indeed low
and we decided to explain it so to
explain this we need to
look at the process of vdg recombination
in more detail
um all immunoglobulin genes are flown by
special sequences called rss
recombination signal sequences and there
are two types of them so
let's call one of them key and another
of them log so keys only can be
recombined with law and rss signals of
the same time can be combined together
that's how
uh the cdj recombination process is
guided so as a result it only created
the j recombinations so we hypothesized
that maybe d genes sometimes have
cryptic logs
and if you just uh
drop this metaphor then you'll see that
these rss are practically a conservative
seven year and conservative nanometer
that are separated by different number
of nucleotides 23 for keys and 12 for
longs so maybe we just need to look for
conserved monomers for degenerates that
are seen in these standard fusions and
that's how a dj recombination can be
taken them for regions or regions and
create this additional step
so when we look at the human genome just
the standard reference we indeed found
that sort nanometers yet
distance 23 for digits and that's how we
could predict transfusions and when we
made this information about observed
diffusion we could explain our observat
95 of our observation so that's actually
a really nice result because now we can
say this
our vddj recombinations are not just a
glitch but there's actually a real
feature of antibody repertoire and as
soon as people have this great
technology we can rely on their
production and this can be a basis of
development of oxygen for hiv
so i just want to give you one more
example how diverse features of
antibiotics could be and for this let's
move from human to cows
so cows have a new immune system and uh
it looks like that can be true for a lot
of different different species
but we started working on cows as a
application of the same tools for
studying responses in them so cows are
susceptible to this bombing respiratory
disease response it's a very costly
disease uh it can be treated and can
only be prevented using uh vaccine
and even in the population of purebred
cows our collaborators observed again
really wide distribution
so genetically similar cows respond to
the same vaccine very very differently
and we decided to study
why this is happening
but before we did it we needed to learn
some specifics about cows and when i
said that they have special immune
system i mean that they also have a
fraction of antibodies produced by the
recombination of the same vdnj genes
that result in a super long antigen
binding group called cdr3 and if you
look at sequences of this cdr3s you'll
see that they have a lot of cysteines at
different positions
and all these cysteines
correspond to the same degen da2 it's a
pretty long degenerate so that's how
ultra long hydrogen binding site is
created and if you look at it we'll see
that it's composed of multiple codons
different from system by a single
substitution so using symmetric
hypergenetic
mutations
sorry
this antibiotics can create cysteines at
different positions
and that's actually one of advantages of
cows because when we observe cysteines
just in the loop they form disulfide
bonds and instead of just being a loop
they can form very diverse structures so
they actually develop additional
mechanism for diversification of
antibodies in addition to vdg
recombination diversity and instead of
being just different from the point of
view of sequences they are different
from the perspective of structures and
that's absolutely unique feature and we
still don't know when exactly it
immersed it looks like it's also present
at some level in years and giraffes
but
uh what actually was the reason of this
we still don't know
so when we analyzed our data we actually
saw that the only
component of immune system that is
boosted by this vaccine is a fraction of
ultra-long antibiotics so they are
responders to the vaccine and we see
that they
kind of correlate positively correlate
with the final responses although this
correlation
uh is not that great as we wanted it to
be so we decided to apply the same
methods as we did for humans we detected
variations in germline genes we
identified clusters of genetically
similar animals so here we analyze three
clusters in order to like make them
larger but you see that there are
smaller groups this is just the pca
representation of genotypes and we saw
that these genotypes first associated
with responses to the vaccine but also
in the cluster that
has higher responses to the vaccine this
correlation is much better as compared
to the whole population so we actually
identified a subset of animals
where
fraction of virtual lung antibiotics is
better correlated with responses and now
we can analyze how exactly
it works and actually because this a
cows people are interested in breeding
cows these animals can be used for
future breeding and these ones can be
ignored
so that shows that first of all methods
can be used for other animals we now
have projects not only for agricultural
animals but also
also for
uh critically endangered animals in
order to keep them healthier like we
work for example on black-rooted ferrets
with smithsonian zoo
but on the other hand it also shows us
how diverse immune systems are and it
makes sense because the only thing that
shapes them is the ability to recognize
pathogens and you can do it in very
different ways
so we got interested in this and we
decided to analyze various mammalian
species unfortunately as a genomes are
currently available for example there is
a virtual brain genome uh project that
has a lot of different species we
started with just with mammals there
were just one of them when we started
those projects two years ago
and we developed a tool called edge
detective it
scans the genome and the nova identifies
immunoglobal engines for species using
both recombination signal sequence
analysis and then relaxed search of
immunoglobulin genes so from this
mammalian species we identified more
than thousand regions so the
this is a great source for new genes and
their analysis and there are different
ways to look at it and i will just talk
about one of them so this is a
phylogenetic tree of all these regions
and we can color them according to the
number of systems that they have in
their sequence against things yeah they
are very important for immunoglobulins
so you see that most of them have two
cysteines they are called canonical and
they form a standard bonds that actually
shapes the conformation of antibody as a
protein but there is a familiar that has
four sustains
and when we analyze species uh that are
in the subgroup he actually saw that
most most of them are bats
and this is interesting because we see
that these two things
emerge at the same position across all
these genes and they correspond to two
other antigen binding loops
that's quite interesting because we
usually think about antigen binding
groups as something very flexible it can
be rotated it can
change its position but if they have
cysteines and if the cysteines are
fixed together
so it means that the composition of
antibody is slightly different it
doesn't have this freedom so we are
interested what kind of antibodies they
are and there is a hypothesis that they
could be highly stable and all beds can
raise and drop their temperature in a
very wide range so humans can do it
human gets sick uh and maybe this
antibodies actually work in the
circumstances because they have more
stable and firm structure so this is
one of the sequences and we actually
also found this and this regions in
squirrels but not in other rodents and
squirrels also have this temperature
feature so that's what we are trying to
investigate now and hopefully with
analysis of more genomes we can
understand more about pathogen
recognition
so thank you so much
for listening i would like to thank my
to my former postdoc advisors bible
personal at ucsd corey watson at
university of louisville
and of course all my collaborators who
are a huge part of this work thank you
so much
uh okay so we have some questions
we're interesting um
can you say a little bit more about how
systematically you look for
non-canonical vdj recombinants such as
the dd fusions
for example do you was it did you
systematically try to find for example
i don't know duplications of j
segments ever or triplicates of the of d
yeah that's a good question so there
were several hypotheses how to explain
the diffusions and uh when we collected
immunoglobulin laser sequences from this
healthy individuals we saw that
duplication indigenes
are practically non-existent they only
have deletions but they still have the
diffusion so it's some process that
emerges
at the level of edge recombination
and there are additional features of
this process that can
uh
work in our favor we always see that
this d diffusion follows the genomic
order of d gene in the genome so they
never kind of come back and it agrees
with the process because it
consecutively cuts uh genomic parts uh
there is no way to come back and connect
digions that don't follow genomic order
so it's still possible in some cases but
i would say that there is a lot of
evidence
for our hypothesis
hi great great talk
as far as i know it may be mistaken the
bovine respiratory disease is caused by
multiple
there are multiple pathogens associated
with
this disease um
how many different
viruses are in the current vaccine that
you looked at
and
if there's more than one
[Music]
how does that influence the selection
patterns for the different v
regions that you're seeing and what was
the nature of the vaccine that was used
was it multiple viruses multiple
organisms
yes that's a great question and
complicated one
so for
for kettle uh
vaccines there is a mixture of four
viruses so the
yeah there are four viruses associated
with this disease and that's basically
why in another uh source of uncertainty
in our data because we currently could
see a mixture of different advantages
and disadvantages
but
yeah there is not that many work was put
in development of oxenous for example
for private uh even flu accents that you
currently
use it's still not super perfect because
it's always a prediction uh of previous
uh and incoming viruses and sometimes it
also can create some optimal responses
that's why people get sequels in
combination with
all these variations so right now i
would say
again this is just my opinion uh
the most sophisticated methods for
vaccine designs are currently
implemented in covetoxins because this
virus was detected at a really
deep level and even if you move to flu
then it's not that great and hopefully
that it's going to be changed with all
these new technologies
um and with uh cows
these technologies are kind of like
still 50 years old so so you really
don't know if these were protective you
just really knew that they were tighters
and this were the
because they were these weren't
challenge experiments after the vaccine
right so
you would
you're really just looking at the clones
sort of a clonal selection uh
more than a protective set of antibodies
in the case of the respiratory disease
so when we uh when i say about these
responses in cows that's actually our
essays for neutralization and uh even
though we have four viruses they all
were measured separately and then they
were come back kind of combined together
so this number
represented the response to follow them
our colleagues analyzed this essays
individually they saw that they all
kind of go up so there are no outliers
and that's why we decided that this
metric is a good representation but
still when we see that they go up there
is still a distribution that some of
them go up better than others and with
respect to your second question i just
want to give a brief overview that um
sometimes we see
very shared motives in immunoglobulin
genes across different species that are
seen in highly diverse genes so genes
themselves are different
but the emotives are conserved and
that's
i think where we can analyze
uh convergent responses to the same
pathogens in different animals
and
hopefully when we see antibodies derived
from these genes you can create these
bridges and say okay it's really
beneficial to have this motive in
antibody in order to successfully
recognize this pathogen because that's
how it was selected by evolution
okay thank you so much i think that we
can move on to them and speaker and we
thank again jana for uh
[Applause]